hi i'm sal khan founder of the khan
academy we're a not-for-profit with a
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere there are
tens of millions of people learning on
khan academy who want to prove what they
know who want to show the world they're
just as capable as folks with more
traditional diplomas
so we're going to make a bridge between
learning on khan academy and real
economic opportunity
to do that we're going to work with
employers and universities all over the
world to identify the skills that people
need most to be successful
then we'll build the content and the
tools that allow anyone starting from
any level to learn those skills to build
the bridge between the learning of the
skills and the opportunities where you
can apply them we're going to create
globally recognized diplomas we're
confident we can do this because we
already have the reach and credibility
with over 100 million learners all over
the world and we have partnerships in
assessment in industry and in higher
education
together i believe that we can do this
and when it happens it's going to bring
hope and opportunity to people all over
the world
when you see khan academy it gives you
hope that there is someone who can bring
change and i'm hopeful that they will be
able to reach to
hundreds and thousands or millions of
children across the world and allow them
and help them to be empowered
i believe in that